this
is not natural
abortion hotel
the embassy beats radish in how are you
doing i don't know
oh my gosh
final question
young ryan howard
what
is michael scott's
greatest fear
um loneliness
maybe women wrong
he's not afraid of anything
also i would have accepted snakes
fear is what it's all about you cannot
sell
while undergoing fear
you need to vanquish fear
one must wrestle
beer
to the ground
you will now wrestle my cousin no okay
all right all right
okay
you're a freak i'm not doing this
anymore and this is over goodbye don't
ryan you don't have to wrestle him ryan
just get in the coffin
ryan
bye ryan
you seem nice
where are all the animals
it's just the wind see nothing all right
you know you don't have to leave the
door wide open we get it it's the wind
just come and shut oh my god
phyllis what's happening this is beet
food moe's what are you doing nomo's put
the put the manure down put it down do
not throw it do not
hey where do i park i'm the valet you
have to give me your car uh you know
what i'm the park i'm the villa you have
to give me your car probably okay
i think it's probably better than the
valet you have
have a good time at the thing it's a
little tricky
[Music]
wow
late every day this week we signed ccf
for this daycare it's on the other side
of town the traffic why didn't i think
of this before did you know that there
is a daycare center opening right here
in this building
is it really now that i own the building
i'm looking for new sources of revenue
and a daycare center
[Laughter]
well i guess it's not an evil idea it's
just a regular idea but
there's no good laugh for a regular idea
welcome to the sesame avenue daycare
center for infants and toddlers
ah
you remember my cousin mose welcome
children were you painting in the dark
wait is this your place dwight oh no i
like to think of it as the kids place
would you like a tour
i don't think we're really ooh let's
take the tour pam yep come on
here is the language skills and
cognitive development area
these are english uh
letters i see you found our magical toy
box jim these are actually forks and
eyes from the break room jam
to you and me maybe but come on to a
child's imagination that's mr fork and
lieutenant knife and
miss fork and a soy sauce packet
that shouldn't have been in there i'm
embarrassed don't beat yourself up we
come fully equipped with uh restroom
feeding trough play bucket and room for
a plant in success who will be watching
the children no one the door locks from
the outside escape is impossible prove
it
what we're gonna head outside
let's give it a whirl i just want to see
how it works oh no no i'll tell you this
if this works out i think we're looking
real good
i promise you that door locks
oh my god
what century is
this had your drink now where's my bride
moe's
what
oh
moe's
[Applause]
[Music]
arise my love my fair one and come away
for lo the winter is past
the rain is over and gone
the time of singing has come
and the voice of the turtle dove is
heard in our land
let me see your face
let me hear your voice
mose could make a great paper salesman
he's got a natural fear of paper which
would motivate him to get as much of it
out of this office as possible i've got
big expectations modes-wise
what quality would make you a good sales
associate
people person
it says here on your resume that you
spent the last 15 years as a sales rep
for dow chemical that's right you know
we live together right
yes and i've never seen you go to work
ever
okay so why is this on your resume
[Music]
okay here we go here we go
put it in
i like um
that's my car
hey
what are you doing
what the hell is going on here
[Applause]
you